les mesures d' emmanuel macron elles ont
profité aux plus riches ne lui en
déplaise alors après il peut lycée avec
une moyenne en disant que tout le monde
dit à gagner mais ceux qui ont
majoritairement gagner sont les plus
riches 300000 personnes qui ont
bénéficié notamment de la réforme de
l'isf à hauteur de 3 milliards d'euros
quand il dit que la taxe d'habitation a
bénéficié en france eh oui c'est 3
milliards d'euros mais là c'est pour 17
millions de français c'est pas tout à
fait la même chose donc on voit bien que
la différence est là c'est à dire que
pour certains le gars le gain moyen
annuel est de 170 euros quand on est
dans les 17 millions par contre pour les
300000 les plus riches ses 9500 euros en
plus grâce à cette suppression isf et
puis les dividendes la flat tax man fait
que les dividendes ont explosé je pense
que vous avez vu les chiffres sur les
milliardaires français dès 10h année
2009 jusqu'à 2020 dont est mené le grand
n'est pas responsable de tout mais quand
même c'est un beau coup un monde dans
lequel il s'inscrit c'est une hausse de
430 9 % de leur fortune des premiers
milliardaires français qui est quelque
chose de jamais vu dans aucun autre pays
du monde c'est même pas quelque chose un
mouvement qui serait international de il
avait un nombre de français faramineux
quatre ou cinq gigantesque permis des 30
premières fortunes du monde aujourd'hui
ce qui n'est jamais arrivé entre temps
le milliardaire anglais le milliardaire
allemand le milliardaire italien à
gagner peut être un peu mais dix fois
moins que ce qu'on gagne et lé
milliardaire français devraient
peut-être se poser une question là
dessus et se demandaient pourquoi et
c'est arrivé simplement par hasard c'est
ça par hasard c'est une politique qui a
bénéficié aux plus riches et peu importe
si emmanuel macron chercha à mentir et à
dire qu'il n'est pas le président des
riches il est dans les faits le
président des riches je ne vois pas je
ne sais pas où habitent les maquereaux
nice ils nous disent que tout va bien
que les plus pauvres ont bénéficié du
pouvoir d'achat toutes les mesures sont
contre les plus pauvres que ce soit
celle de la réforme de l'assurance
chômage que ce soit l'inflation qui
existe qui est réel il n'y a pas eu de
hausse des salaires on est resté sur un
gel des salaires des fonctionnaires avec
quelques primes qui ont été là parce que
les gilets jaunes ont été les premiers à
se plaindre justement de cette perte de
pouvoir d'achat et eux continuent de
dire que tout va bien alors que les
queues s'allongent devant les banques
alimentaires y compris pour les
étudiants y compris pour des gens qu'il
n'y était jamais allé
et alors le covin n'expliquera pas ton